we had the 20th anniversary of 9 11 over
the weekend
and um there is
so much that can be said and yet how
much is there that is new that can be
said about 911 that we've not said on
prior anniversaries for me one of the
most important things
was the stark contrast
over the 20 years between the 2021
republican party
and the 2001 republican party
and how out of place
then president george w bush looks
within the modern republican party now
whoa whoa whoa
am i rewriting history and
rehabilitating the image of george w
bush no that's not what i'm doing
am i saying george w bush's foreign
policy decisions back in 2001 and two
and three made any sense no
no i'm not doing that
but what i am pointing out is as much of
a disaster as was george w bush on
foreign policy and in so many other ways
the republican party today under the
maga brand
has become something
orders of magnitude more insane and so
what i'm going to play for you here is a
little bit of a speech that george w
bush gave
um on saturday on the anniversary of 9
11
in which he did something that i think
is really accurate actually
he likened
the trump rioters of january 6th
to the 9 11 terrorists
of 9 11 2001 and pointed out it's not
just from abroad
that these threats can come
but even from inside as well
now i i want to again say
in this speech george w bush says a ton
of nonsense i don't like bush i don't
think he was a good president i didn't
vote for but you know all these
different things even in this speech
bush still acts like his military
actions in afghanistan and iraq made
sense i don't agree with that
but
he correctly draws a line
between the trump rioters and the 911
terrorists and saying it's all
people who wish harm or want to do harm
to the united states let's take a listen
to george w bush on saturday
as a nation our adjustments have been
profound
many americans struggled to understand
why an enemy would hate us with such
zeal
the security measures incorporated into
our lives
are both sources of comfort
and reminders of our vulnerability
but this is an example the security
measures are also something that many of
us are concerned
are sacrificing privacy without really
providing security like that's a huge
part of security measures you know so so
there's still a ton of neocon propaganda
here but he eventually gets to something
very important
and we have seen growing evidence
that the dangers to our country can come
not only across borders right
but from violence that gathers within
right
there is a little cultural overlap
between violent extremists abroad and
violent extremists at home
but in their disdainful pluralism
in their disregard for human life
in their determination to defile
national symbols
they are children of the same foul
spirit
and it is our continuing duty to
confront them
he is
absolutely right
i saw a great comment on reddit which
said
in an attempt to be the most
conservative member of their party
they're becoming so reactionary that
they're starting to reject basic aspects
of human civilization
like empathy for others that can't
directly help you
and that is exactly the type of thing
that george w bush is pointing to now
again because i know
you know the the glenn greenwald types
are very quick to say look at all these
soft leftists
lionizing bush and uh forgetting no no
no no no even in this speech bush acts
like his military actions in iraq and
afghanistan made sense
uh after trump though bush comparatively
sounds
relatively empathetic
comparatively wise and we have to still
remember all the bad we're not rehabbing
george w bush
but
um it is a stark contrast here
between what the republican party was in
2001 which was already horrible it was
horrible in 2001 to what it is today i
get the sense that bush as a person
feels much more comfortable and safe
around the obamas
than the trumpists and this is also a
reminder that the obama democratic party
is not the the super left socialist
thing that the right believes it to be
that's an important reminder here as
well now the problem is when you try to
talk about this stuff everybody wants
black and white david do you think bush
is great or do you think he's terrible
well he was horrible on policy
for the times of 2001 to three he was a
disgusting reactionary a terrible neocon
and he has accurately identified the
lunatic stray of the republican party to
trumpism and has accurately found an
analogy between the trump rioters and
the 911 terrorists that's it you know
people want oh if bush gets along with
obama
that means obama is actually a right
winger no obama's a center-left democrat
bush is a is a republican but compared
to mag occultists who at every
opportunity do what is absolutely worst
for the country they are closer to each
other in that way while still being
significantly different politically and
part of the problem is
it's not just the people on the right
who want to say oh obama's a socialist
marxist biden's a socialist marxist
there's also people on the left who want
to say if there's any agreement between
a republican and a democrat it must mean
the democrat is actually a right winger
let's try not to fall for these tired
tropes that are completely
counterproductive in actually discussing
substantively the issues facing the
country bush was a disaster
and good for bush triggering the maga
people by saying the january 6 people
are more similar to the 911 terrorists
than you might think now one other
thought
on twitter and reddit i saw these
right-wing nuts saying
when bush referred to the domestic
people he was talking about antifa and
black lives matter no he wasn't he
obviously wasn't there's no way in hell
that that's what george w bush was
talking about let's take a quick break
we'll have more on this
and the rest of today's stories on our
instagram which you can find at david
pakman's show
one of our sponsors is sheath underwear
it's summer right now in the northern
hemisphere it's hot it's humid many of
the men in my audience know about the
discomfort that can come with this with
traditional underwear the sweating the
chafing the sticking not fun
and that's what sheath underwear has
solved
sheath has designed men's boxer briefs
with multiple ergonomic compartments
built into the front of the underwear
which keeps everything separate dry cool
and comfortable all day long
sheath has re-released two limited
edition styles
flower of life with a stylish flower
pattern and bold geometric waistband the
other limited edition style is the mesh
airflow especially designed to be
lightweight and promote extra coolness
and breathability
give sheath underwear a try i've had a
great experience with it i think you
will too you can find the link
underneath this video and don't forget
to use promo code pacman for twenty
percent off